[Music]  the other side of the world  i wonder if i've gone far enough perhaps  it's as my father said  no matter how far you run you can never  escape yourself  [Music]  do you come on behalf of england we are  on a voyage of discovery  not conquest god this is  [Music]  why paradise i feel myself suck deeper  and deeper upriver  but i do not lose things for here i am a  stranger  hey even to myself lenon raiders  pirates  i wouldn't go in there alone you  understand your vessel has many cannons  lord brooke  we would like to see these cannons  there's more going on here than meets  the eye  you can't run from this chase  to have peace we must make war  this is war  you could be okay  [Music]  i was given a sword to rule a kingdom  larger than england  but i've had enough of killing  i've been living in a fantasy of my own  [Music]  making to rule the jungle  i must love the jungle all of it  the beauty and the blood  you